- This video was made
possible by Tab For A Cause.
Raise money for charity
just by opening tabs
which you were going to do anyway.
Link in the description.
(sighs)
So what's new?
It's actually really weird
recording from my own kitchen.
Feels like I would have
a Peter McKinnon-style
coffee montage, but I don't
really drink coffee that much.
(upbeat rock music)
(water dribbles)
So, I've never seen anything like this.
I graduated from law school in 2008,
right in the middle of the recession,
and you can imagine
that joining a big firm
in the middle of what was until now
the worst recession that
we had seen in modern times
was a very dramatic time to
become a practicing lawyer.
That is nothing compared
to what it seems like
we're in the middle of right now.
I'm from Los Angeles, but
for the last five years,
I have lived in DC, and I consider myself
a Washingtonian now,
and I'm really worried
because I go to the same gym as Rand Paul.
(chuckles nervously)
I'm gonna get some crap for that.
But I thought that because
things are so crazy
and so up in the air, people might want
an update from Legal Eagle.
What does this mean for the channel?
And frankly, because we're all basically
stuck at our houses, my hope is that
the channel will more or less
continue as it always has.
I find it incredibly rewarding that people
turn to my channel for
entertainment and education.
Right now, I think we
could all use a little bit
more information about the world,
especially the legal world
that we're surrounded by,
and also a little entertainment
and a little light-hearted
fun from time to time.
The power of attorney!
I get a lot of joy out of
making these videos for people.
I find it very rewarding
when I get nice comments
in the comments section, and
when people leave bad comments,
your hatred fuels me.
So for the most part,
I'm really just going to
try and continue as I always have
with real legal work sort of drying up
because the courts are
more or less closed,
I'm gonna try and
increase video production.
It's usually one video
a week on this channel,
I'm gonna try for at least two.
I'm going to keep all of my staff going,
I think it's the least that I could do
in times when we don't know
what's going to happen,
at least those privileged
few who can work from home,
I'm going to do my part
to try to make sure
that those people get a paycheck,
and there are a fair number
of people that rely on me,
on this channel and the work that I do,
and I feel like I owe it to them
to try and continue that work.
Oh, and this is an issue for another day,
but I have a super secret legal
project that I'm working on
that predates all of this
crazy coronavirus stuff.
Man, I can't wait to
tell you what's going on.
It involves a law suit, and
it may involve the government.
This could be a really,
really interesting thing,
but that's gonna have to wait
until things are a little bit more solid,
and it's more in progress,
but I can't wait to tell you about it.
So that's an update from
Legal Eagle the channel,
but I suppose that since we're
in this intimate setting,
we might as well do an
update from Devin personally.
What I intend to do personally is
whatever I can to keep things going,
to try and make things a little bit better
for those people especially
in the service industry
that can't simply work from home.
I'll probably be thanking
my delivery people
like they are soldiers
returning home from war.
On YouTube, I'm gonna try and help out
as many creators as I possibly can.
I would love to do some
collabs with people,
especially smaller channels,
people that are perhaps
interested in the law
but might not be in the
legal sector in particular,
though I'm certainly open to working with
other legal creators as well.
Obviously charities are a huge thing.
We need to band together
to be able to help
the less fortunate, those
who are really being affected
by this coronavirus isolation quarantine,
and what seems like an
inevitable economic downturn.
For example, this video you'll find a link
to Tab For A Cause, which has been
a long time supporter of this channel.
It's great because they're teaming up with
a bunch of coronavirus-specific
related charities,
and it's great because all you have to do
is install a Chrome
extension and do surfing,
which I think we're all
going to be doing a lot of
web surfing these days.
Just generates ad revenue that's donated
to whatever charities
that you direct it to.
Additionally, with
increased video production,
I'll probably have some
additional opportunities
to partner with charities to
directly sponsor the channel.
We can take all of the proceeds
and donate it to various
effective charities.
So those of you that are
out there in the comments,
if you could leave me some suggestions
on which charities I should partner with,
I would greatly appreciate being able to
be directed to the most
effective charities
to be able to combat
the coronavirus threat.
I think that there are a lot of people
doing a lot of good work out there.
We owe an enormous debt of gratitude
to doctors, nurses,
and other medical staff
that are out there that are on
the front lines of this thing
and they're literally risking their lives
to help everyone else.
So in terms of being able
to do what I can as a lawyer
with very minimal, (chuckles)
to put it graciously,
very minimal medical training,
I would like to be able to help
those that are on the front lines.
And in terms of what I intend
to do with my free time
now that we all have a lot of free time,
well I think like most people,
I'm looking forward to
cooking a lot of meals
in this kitchen where I
spend a lot of of my time.
I'm looking forward to
doing a whole lot of
body weight workouts here at home.
I'm looking forward to bettering myself
and doing a lot of e-learning.
As I'm sure long-time
viewers of the channel know,
Legal Eagle is sponsored by
companies like Skillshare
and Brilliant, and there's
a good reason for it.
There are companies out there
where I don't necessarily
agree with their mission.
(coughs) Raid Shadow Legends.
But it's really easy to work
with companies like Skillshare
and Brilliant because I really
believe in their mission,
and I believe in people getting better
by learning the things that are necessary
and then practicing that on their own,
and these kind of e-learning platforms
allow us a wealth of knowledge that
we wouldn't have had even 10 years ago.
So like everybody else, I'm gonna learn
a lot of new skills.
Maybe this is too personal,
but I'm a really bad dancer,
so I think I'd like to learn how to dance,
especially when no one's looking.
So if you have any tips on where I can go
to learn some dance moves online,
leave them in the comments
and I'd appreciate it.
You know, I think with some of this time,
I'll be on social media more.
So if you follow me on Twitter,
I will probably be trying
to avoid going stir crazy
by venting my frustrations
on Twitter and Instagram,
and you know, I don't
feel like now is really
the right time to start a Patreon,
but maybe if there was something
that I could really add
to the community that you guys wanted,
and maybe if the proceeds from the Patreon
went to my staff, for example,
or some other charity,
I would be open to it.
If there's something that I can do
to get better acquainted with
all the Legal Eagles out there
and people who are interested
in the law, I'm open to ideas.
So let's end with some
optimism and some thankfulness.
Let's end with a couple of the things
that I'm actually really
looking forward to
about this whole isolation
and quarantine situation.
Number one, I'm looking
forward to all of the people
that are going to be
getting their law degrees
on Twitter and Facebook.
You might not have heard,
but the Zuckerberg Law School
in Paolo Alto became an
accredited ABA law school,
so all of those people
who are pontificating
about legal subjects on social media,
they probably actually
have their law degrees now.
(laughs) Oh god.
- Let's see what your best move is.
(slapping)
- I'm looking forward to buying
a whole lot of new scotch.
(chuckles) One of my favorite bars in DC,
Jack Rose, is weathering
the storm by selling
thousands of bottles of
antique and vintage scotch,
and I think I'm just gonna buy all of it.
Bill Thomas, please, please
save me some bottles.
I'm looking forward to all of the new
insane legal theories that
I'm going to have to research
and talk about during
this isolation period.
You know, I thought when
Donald Trump became president
in 2017 that uh, that
alone was going to create
a whole bunch of new legal hypotheticals,
and that was definitely the case,
but (sighs) man,
there are a whole bunch of crazy things
that we never thought would ever happen
that we have to figure
out the legality of,
and it's every day a new legal theory.
- This is a tough hurricane.
One of the wettest we've ever seen
from the standpoint of water.
- And frankly, I'm looking forward to
the entire world coming
together for a common cause.
This is the first time in my lifetime,
and maybe the last time
since the Apollo project
that it feels like everyone
is rallying together
against a common enemy, and
this isn't a common enemy
in the xenophobic sense or
even in the true wartime sense,
but there's something out
there and it affects everyone,
and every scientist in the
entire world is trying to fix it.
Things are dire right now, for sure,
but they're not gonna stay that way,
because humans are nothing if not clever.
This might be our finest hour,
and I'm happy to do
what I can to help out,
whether it's through making
stupid YouTube videos
or through helping out with charities,
but I think we all owe
scientists and doctors
out there a debt of gratitude,
not only for what they're doing right now,
but what they're going to do,
because I think that,
to paraphrase Andy Weir,
I think we're gonna science
the (bleep) out of it.
I think we're gonna
come out of this better.
You know, there's light
at the end of the tunnel.
So that is an update from Legal Eagle.
I will see you all in court, as it were.
If you want a really low barrier to entry
way of providing to charity,
check out the link to Tab For A Cause.
Send me a message in the
comments or on Twitter.
I'm going to be here,
what else do I have to do?
And thank you, to you the
viewers, the Legal Eagles.
I get a lot of satisfaction
for doing this channel,
and I'm really grateful
for being in the position
that I am and you guys make it worth it.
Hang in there, we'll get through this,
and I'll see you in court.